tonight is the fourth night of hanukkah  um which i celebrate with my daughters  and um this is our pick from the little  yellow book which is my personal guide  to things that i would love for you to  know about  and  this awesome menorah wall hanging is  made by pockets of learning so i  received this and i had to share and a  big thanks to you at modern tribe for  sending this to us modern tribe has so  many fun unique jewish gifts on their  site  moderntribe.com i celebrate hanukkah  with my girls and this is very special  and i just can't wait to hang it up so  thank you so much you guys for choosing  to spend your time with us we make this  show for you so take it with you  [Music]